the PlayStation 4's had a damn good year
and while technically it's probably
easier to argue for the console that's
winning the total sales race we have
just seen Microsoft take out its first
month selling more Xbox ones than ps4 so
where does sony go from here Sony have
the one up in a few different ways
including that the ps4 is the more
powerful console Microsoft may have one
last generation but the fact that ps4
has proved it can more consistently
deliver 1080p resolution and 60fps frame
rates is significant at a time when
gamers are voicing how much technical
prowess matters to them this is the
chance for Sony to get up prove they
have it and keep working with developers
to make sure that'll keep being the case
last year I did a video on how Nintendo
was gonna sell a whole bunch of we youth
and they did part of the reason I
proposed that was due to the fact that
it was the only new gen console with
backwards compatibility but Sony has the
power to change that Sony announced
PlayStation now a while back as a
streaming service which is supposed to
let you play all the PlayStation 3 games
through your ps4 and of course there is
already a large selection of ps1 and ps2
games available for digital download on
the PlayStation Store at the moment
they're one of the huge problems with
PlayStation now is that the rental
period prices associated with the games
on offer are just way too high up to $50
to rent certain titles for 90 days if
Sony give their pricing model for PS now
under control this could be a huge
selling point for ps4 this year Sony had
a bit of a problem last generation with
the ps3 in the wallet offered a bunch of
interesting gameplay experiences it was
never attractive as a multiplayer
console since everybody was on Xbox Live
for 2015 only need to continue turning
that around for the ps4 a huge win for
Sony last year was the success of
destiny and the fact that gamers playing
on the ps4 have been treated first with
exclusive content and
see the effort they put into the destiny
phenomenon has begun to convince people
that Sony care about fostering that
vibrant multiplayer environment at the
same time there isn't a sense that Sony
is losing the slew of unique games that
define the ps3 the order 1886 no man's
sky and blood-borne are all console
exclusives to the ps4 set to land this
year which are drawing a lot of
attention and early hype
although exclusives aren't as common as
they used to be so nice in to be taking
hold of a few key titles including the
recently announced Street Fighter 5 one
of the biggest competitive multiplayer
games around at one point everybody was
backing the oculus rift and it was
saying that Sony's project Morpheus was
something of a bandwagon jumper but now
that the whole Facebook debacle has
tarnished the reputation of the oculus
rift it seems that project Morpheus is
back in the spotlight since Microsoft is
still yet to dip their figurative toe
into the virtual reality scene at the
moment it's due to be a two horse race
between oculus and Sony and Sony's
project Morpheus is actually looking
really cool the peripheral integrates
smoothly with existing PlayStation
hardware the HD display is crisp and it
turns out that Sony money plus a really
good development team I'm making for an
awesome piece of hardware even if it is
just a prototype at the moment Virtual
Reality is certainly still finding its
footing but Sony is well on its way to
proving that it can and will work on
consoles even when this is made
available to the public there's a good
chance it will make naturally curious
gamers came to pick up a ps4 to try out
the suspected future of video games Sony
have learned a lot of hard lessons from
last generation but with the right games
the promise of virtual reality and
backwards compatibility the ps4 could
well continue to dominate through 2015
those are my arguments for either
console but let me know which one you
think will have the edge and what you
want to see Sony and Microsoft doing it